[Music]
i did what i had to do
to protect our world
it's pretty unfathomably exciting where
are we going in this film it's the most
fantastic new phase of marvel
what do you know about the multiverse
this had his theories he believed it was
dangerous
in this story we are leaping into
different universes but unlocking the
multiverse creates a big pandora's box
you open the doorway and we don't know
who or what will walk through it
we're in unknown territory
i think audiences are going to be
startled these other realities invite a
plethora of all these new characters
[Music]
telling the stories was such a gigantic
endeavor
it had to be large because it had to not
only paint a picture of our universe but
of multiple universes
we need your help it was a great
opportunity to pair two of the most
powerful superheroes together
it's got a sort of darker tone to it and
with sam remy at the helm he's a master
of that
we wanted the fans to go oh how cool i
mean that really was our goal we wanted
to give the fans what they wanted just
not exactly what they expected
the stakes are real he's literally
coming up against versions of himself
things just got out of hand
[Music]
every night
i dream the same dream
then
the nightmare begins
i did what i had to do
to protect our
world you can't control everything
strange
you open the doorway between universes
and we don't know who or what will walk
through it
wonder what do you know about the
multiverse this had his theories
he believed it was dangerous
he was right
i'm sorry stephen
[Music]
your desecration of reality
will not go unpunished
[Music]
we should tell him the truth
[Music]
things just got out of hand
[Music]
you break the rules
become a
hero i do it i become the enemy
[Music]
it doesn't seem fair
right
[Music]
[Music]
you